well we invited the voice of ghost face
here this week to introduce the stellar
cast take it away
please welcome dylan minnette
mason gooding
jasmine savoy brown
mikey madison and sonia amar
[Applause]
i'm just so excited to meet all of you
guys in um
zoom person
um
and we're all dying to know who
ghostface is and it's so secret
that is it true none of you knew during
the filming sonia
yeah
yeah they gave us different scripts and
different versions with different
endings so it kind of kept this whodunit
fun game off screen for us uh which
was a really fun experience yeah
um
mason
is it true that you wrote an essay about
scream and you sent it to the directors
after your audition
what was that about
that listen
when you do something in college you
obviously operate under the assumption
that that'll remain in that atmosphere
didn't think i'd have to necessarily
answer for it five years later but
um
yes i wrote an essay about the uh
potential for revival in the scream
franchise and how um
in this current media landscape it would
actually be incredibly appropriate
but um i figured it was appropriate uh
to send their way
uh i guess it it either helped in some
way or they were like well i guess he
sent that essay but other than that he
seemed fine
we'll take the rest in stride i also
want to like ask you a quick uh parent
advice because your father is cuba
gooding jr
i mean hello
and
i i like that he as i want to do with my
kids whenever they talk about an
interest in the business i'm like just
be of a developed mind before you go out
into that big world
that's right well first and foremost he
asked if i could do anything else uh
maybe
a sport
or a um vocation that didn't involve so
much mass rejection but
once it seemed like a more viable option
something i truly wanted to do
i think the discussion was about how to
do it authentically and how to do it
when
i was ready and mature enough in a way
to let any perception both social
public or personal to be when i was
both ready to mentally kind of handle it
and process it well
it makes me happy to know that that's
the rules i have for my kids and um
because i care so much about their
psychology which leads me to a question
from mikey
because your parents are psychologists
and
what did they talk to you about
doing a film like this whether it was
like what this does to society how
should you play a character like the one
you're playing i'm not giving anything
away
but boy what a resource tell me
everything you
can yeah well both my parents are
clinical psychologists so um growing up
i think they were always
psychoanalyzing me just a little bit but
i think that also gave me a different
understanding to characters like why
they do things and i um do have this
sort of like different understanding of
of characters and sort of like the
psychology that goes on behind that i
love that um one of my favorite people
on planet earth who i've literally known
my whole life is david arquette and
jasmine david came on the show and he
was talking about
um
he had taken this bob ross course on how
to
teach painting and
yeah he taught you painting
yeah he decided to buy all of us a bob
ross painting kit and teach us how to
paint in the style of bob ross we spent
a whole day
he was our teacher he took us through
all the steps and then bought a ton more
canvases so we could go down to the
conference room that we'd rent it out
and do it whenever we want um okay dylan
this movie uh plays homage to the
original
is there any callbacks that we should
like look out for
um
i mean i feel like uh
the easter eggs and the homages are all
over the place um even down to the clip
that you played just before you were um
speaking to us like i i sort of um
considered this a spoiler in my head but
now that it's been on television and
we're talking about it um mikey and i
are sharing a bag of grapes
and uh in the initial scene um at the
high school in the original screen
they're also eating a bag of grapes in
that scene uh the original uh team cass
and things like that are all over the
place and i feel like this this movie um
is a perfect meta
takedown of the genre and a love letter
to the genre just like the original was
i think they captured it very well in
this very very well said dylan um okay
jasmine i heard that um you sang karaoke
um with courtney cox
um
give us a little fly on the wall moment
who's saying what
okay
sonia sang la vian rose and it was the
most beautiful version i've ever heard
in my life
and that's really all i can remember
because it just knocked everybody out of
the water someone's amazing seeing her
dylan is obviously icing this is a
talented cat i know the three of you do
music and you can see the proof i have
right here
um for sonia was i know that you're a
karaoke
er so i wanted to ask you what's your
go-to karaoke song oh that's yeah i love
karaoke i've literally been seeing
karaoke since i'm
i don't know six years old i remember
that was like on a computer and
my favorite song to sing um
like i will survive or
that is not an easy song to sing i will
survive
just like a big fun song that everyone
can sing along too you know
[Music]